it's the holiday season outside it's
cold and there's snow blanketing the
ground
but inside you're warm and gathered
around the light of a roaring fireplace
and a glowing christmas tree
this is what christmas is all about
warmth joy and togetherness but just
because you're comfortable doesn't mean
you're safe you were so busy opening
presents and stuffing yourself at dinner
that you didn't notice the face pressed
up against the window
that long gaunt face with the staring
eyes
the wide mouth full of yellow teeth and
the scraggly
white beard you don't know it yet
but within a few days you'll be dead you
might be able to avert this horrible
fate
if you knew what exactly you were
dealing with scp-4666
also known as the yule man a
ketter-class christmas monster
so violent sadistic and terrifying he
makes krampus look like jolly saint nick
and this year just like every other he's
planning on being
very very naughty the scp foundation
began cataloging the yule man in 1974
after a string of violent and eerily
similar home invasions during the
holiday season
but they have reason to believe that
this entity has been around for a whole
lot longer
over 2 000 years in fact stories that
describe what looked to be yule man
massacres date back as far as the first
century bc
in scandinavia and there have been
reports of similar clusters of events
happening around the same time
every year since this monster is
prolific
and may have one of the highest body
counts of any creature under
observation by the foundation the yule
man's trail of destruction became
clearer in the 18th century
as accounts of the carnage it leaves
became more detailed
later still authorities even managed to
find physical evidence like the yule
man's fingerprints
which are similar to human fingerprints
but display a distinct double whirl
pattern not seen in human fingerprints
much about the anomalous nature of the
yule man is still unknown though
and the foundation has yet to discover
an effective way to contain it
their only hope is intercepting it
before it can get its long
gnarled fingers on its intended prey
maybe you're feeling worried or that
you're being watched
you have good reason to be afraid
because during his yearly active period
the 12 days between december 21st and
january 2nd
he's always searching for prey nowhere
is safe
because while it was initially believed
that he only appeared to those who live
north of 40 degrees latitude
it's now believed that much like santa
claus the yule man
operates worldwide anyone could be in
his sights right now blissfully unaware
of the nightmare coming down the tracks
towards them
thankfully the scp foundation through
analysts of these attacks which are
known as weissnacht the vents
they've been able to find certain
patterns but first
what does the creature known as the yule
man even look like
much like scp-096 the yule man is a long
and lanky humanoid
standing about 2 meters tall who
resembles an emaciated human of european
descent
and never wears any clothes or other
coverings despite the frigid
temperatures he operates in
you might be sad if you're spending
christmas alone but it at least
guarantees you safety from the yule man
as he only appears at the homes of
families with a child under the
age of eight present he also seems to
favor isolated and rural locations
and vicenoct events only occur when
there's a healthy covering of snow
on the ground during the event hence the
name which means
white knight in english it's also vital
that you recognize the three distinct
stages of a vice knock event 2
or you won't be seeing much of the new
year the first stage occurs during the
space of a week
children in the home might start to seem
worried or afraid
they might tell you that they see
something strange in the distance
the figure of a man they don't recognize
standing just far enough away that you
can't fully make him out
except that he's really tall of course
you probably won't see
anything and your instinct will be to
tell them there's nothing to be afraid
of
even when they tell you through tears
that there's a man
pressing his face up against their
bedroom window at night
but they are right to be afraid and you
should be too
already at this point your only hope is
to try and spread the word as soon as
possible
report the incident to the local police
write about it on facebook
tweet about it whatever it takes the scp
foundation has operatives trawling the
internet and monitoring police reports
constantly during this period
especially for reports of mysterious men
in the snow
watching homes from a distance getting
the foundation's attention is your best
hope of stopping this thing
and if you don't next comes stage two
taking place between knights eight and
eleven of the active period
no longer will the yule man just be
lurking on the periphery
now he's getting closer you'll start to
hear strange noises in your attic or on
the roof
noises that sound almost like footsteps
that's crazy
you think it's probably just an animal
but then
the smell starts an awful rotten stench
that
fills the house but no matter how hard
you look
you can't find the source finally on the
last night of december you'll tell
yourself that you'll take this matter to
the police
but of course it's already too late
the yule man is here for the twelfth
night the vice knocked
is finally upon you at this point one of
two scenarios will happen
in the first you and your entire family
will be tortured and murdered
except the youngest child who the yule
man will kidnap
the scp foundation keeps files on a
number of notable instances of this kind
of ice knock
and the details are truly gruesome
reports of incidents have involved
crucifixion
the removal of tongues burning
dismemberment
postmortem bite marks and decapitation
in all instances though the entire
family was killed except the youngest
child who simply disappeared the yule
man is a merciless and sadistic beast
you're now probably wondering if that's
the first of two vicenock possibilities
what's the second in the second if
you're tremendously lucky
you and your family will survive but
that doesn't mean you won't face a
grisly experience
in this scenario which occurs during
about 15 percent of ice knocked events
you'll hear footsteps throughout the
night but thankfully you wake up alive
and when you do so there are gifts
waiting for you
the problem is all these gifts are made
out of human body parts
for example in 1976 in canada one family
received the gift of a ball made from a
severed human head
wrapped in skin in kazakhstan in 1903
a family received a flute made from a
hollowed-out human femur
and in the netherlands in 2003 a family
received a wooden hairbrush
covered in human teeth ranging from 400
years old to a mere
few days these gruesome gifts are
referred to as
scp-4666-a
and it was one of these gifts that gave
us the best insight yet available
into the true nature of the yule man
several gifts were dropped off at a
family's residence in huna alaska
in 2018 but most notably among them was
the horrific
scp-4666-a-0960
a life-size doll made from a human body
with its eyes removed and mouth sewn
shut
worst of all though was that the girl
was still
alive the family who received this
twisted gift was given amy's sticks by
the foundation
and the living doll was taken for
medical treatment before succumbing to
her extensive injuries
the girl was able to deliver some
insights into what exactly happened to
the children
who were abducted during vicenoct events
the children taken by the yule man are
forced into a large sack that seems much
bigger on the inside than it appears as
he makes his rounds
traveling from house to house murdering
and kidnapping
his victims are taken to a kind of
underground grotto
and workshop filled with bones like a
twisted santa's workshop
where they're forced to make toys out of
the bodies of their fellow victims
during this time the yule man will
continue to torture
and torment his victims he'll even take
some of them away to cook and
eat whenever he feels like it when asked
how she was turned into this human doll
the girl told foundation personnel that
her fellow victims were forced to turn
her into this by the yule man
when she became too weak to continue
making toys
herself her chilling last words were
when you can't make the toys
you become the toys so if strange things
happen to you and your family between
the 21st of december
and the 1st of january don't ignore it
after all
you never know who's watching but if it
is the yule man's grinning
face pressed up against your window it
may already
be too late happy holidays
now go check out scp-4000 taboo
and scp-2317 the devourer of worlds for
more